go squad 94 one boot leg calf backstage
shout out to my do Mac Miller just
killed it pretty usual we do if we do
man you don't mean uh I like to just
make sure everyone has a great time with
their mind body and soul yeah man listen
last tour you have a live band yeah
which was so crazy I remember that tour
I don't know if I remember like
everybody else cuz I was blowing out of
my mind the first time I ever did anibal
dance and I jabbed with action backstage
so I was on another level but like it
was the internet right yeah the internet
was the band more ego Doug yeah so what
is the difference for you energy wise
doing the what you did tonight with the
DJ and what keywords you're hired man is
compared to when you've got the live
band all is different because so when
you have like like i love i love both
right right for different reasons um
like the band is like like a very it's a
very like it's like an experience and it
was very like musical and a little bit
is a little bit chilly yeah for sure
yeah is um and other thing that you get
is you do you're doing like
interpretations of Records yep it's the
records change a little bit right you're
making new version which is cool so it
was like okay um but what do I like was
with when it's just us up there is I
just the energy is like it's real like
[__] everyone's going nuts who knows
it's a lot more of energy showin s up I
really wanted that for for this tour I
thinking next time is when we like
combine my house I'm making you know one
hundred percent do you feel like I feel
like there was a you've had a few stages
in your career I feel like you had a
stage where kids came out best day ever
came out and you had your hardcore fans
but you have like a lot of their like
real hip-hop Doozer Hayden right for
sure whose side part came out I feel
like I mean it did it staying on the
charts but I flag a lot I mean you know
it was it was a good it wasn't your best
project right people people hate it I'll
never I never I love the project there
was good record it was it was it was a
proud
for a certain time for for uh it was a
certain idea that you know it might not
it might not be I I don't think I was as
as as mature with with how I wanted to
make a project you know I think it was
my first album and um yeah it better but
you know and a lot of people arguably
would say that you came out with the
best album the day that you Kanye Cole
dropped mommy yeah people some people
say that you know mean I read that music
rap song of the year 2013 hey I'm just
throwing out there and just so real talk
back road is oh you know yeah I mean I
I'm you know I'd do my thing I think it
it was just really dope to see uh to see
that shift in people you know and it
wasn't no bitterness on my part nice i'm
like oh you hated and for the record you
always have held it down for like the
boom bap [__] from the jump weather was
working with static shouting out big l
or gray I mean all that [__] you got it
I mean for me like you gotta be able to
be versatile and do two different types
of things you know like um like I like
that's one of my favorite parts about
what I do is I can do a record like When
in Rome right in the bag and then also
you know do some [__] like perfect
circle or leg break the law um often new
record so yeah man ha it's been nice to
see to see the growth and more people
kind of really just paying attention and
coming out and show in love and seeing
like different types of people starting
to come to shows that's why this record
has been so dope because it was kind of
like like the second record kind of like
ever was like oh [__] like you know like
yes I didn't expect this and then
something it was really like then I feel
like Macadelic like really solidified
right now like yo I'm real I correct my
drug
let's be clear Mac Macadelic to me is
one like one of my illness product is my
favorite project the reason I stood like
with the way was created is brilliant I
think it's been the only project that I
made where it was like I'm had the idea
for what the concept was made 16 songs
and then 15 like only cut once wow
that's been like every other project got
make it's like so much recording happens
so Macadelic was so dope to me because I
felt like it was just like dislike
hygiene and I want to set out I did it
and you've been independent like that's
been your big thing I remember I think
it was did you break was a dog pounds
record for the highest hindi adult
dependent maybe wow it was a for dog
food yeah but it wasn't like I was the
first number one independent so make
your sentence in yes yes it hey Michael
Buble right I did that's tight I
remember I was in Vegas like two days
before the final numbers came out he
came by the station yeah but now that
you're with the major joint that you got
your situation with Warner Brothers and
Warner Brothers is historically known to
like work well with artists that already
have something independently going on is
there a difference do you feel the
difference is there anything different
in the creative process is enough
pressure nothing nothing to create a
process i wanted to like i wanted to
just I want to make sure that that we
remained doing things how we do things
oh like we have a team of people there
that help make it up there like how to
build it and make it like global right
and grow it um but like I didn't I
didn't really want to change much you
know I just it was important for me to
like for that for nothing to be
different for my fans to and whoever is
gonna be a new fan to get the same me
like it's just me you know it's like
direct relation
supporting hundred percent this is in
turn Adrian he's like melon lesson meet
you this is my insurance money still of
young intern Ares is a die-hard Mac
Miller fan I got a little while I just
got one question that this is all he
wants to know okay and it's a good
question where the [__] did you find my
chance for faces like real cuz I
honestly thought like Jay Electronica
like you topped it I was like what how
did you find that like brought to
mcdonalds napkin it was inside you don't
find me Mike Jones I was like wow what
is my goons come fro because because
what was harder my Jones are Rick Ross
to get or just like what would to me
what was bigger for me oh my god I mean
like like the rick ross song I'm not a
lot like went when he said when Rick
Ross sent me the verse that was a moment
in my life yeah where I was like hell
yeah all the ones all the homies getting
like we're on a studio and we are
listening like holy SH damn he didn't
wreck this we really do this but like
mike jones was more of like a holy [__]
like I just got [__] Mike where'd you
find the legs you go on this Twitter how
did I get oh yeah how do i define a
bank's girls it's what I still did you
call the phone number no I called you I
1330 8005 I go like oh [__] Aaron stood
on time I rufino's like my job and then
after like three months he just games
smiley Jesus birth no say my name good I
yo you go no no I use that Mike good i
said my job so no uh-uh i think i'm on
twitter and you know i'm like i like do
it like i really like doing that [__]
with features like like grabbing really
unexpected people you're up you're
stalking us you've gone from sean price
to Miguel yeah right a electronic we
gotta get everybody any I appreciate
that you just did man like i just threw
me goes on [__] yo yo
rustling watching wrestling what and the
stuff that jabroni is fire hygiene rock
tweeted the rock retweet it but I want
to know he just tweeted I want to know
first of all you did let's let's talk
about you you came out to you came back
out to stick me with it right of course
s'mores is a you pay attention top
something I'm waiting I'm just waiting
for it to get it up bass tone I don't
know why is it a 2 in WrestleMania not
Mac Miller we got to figure this out we
got to swap out the white rappers doing
but I think I think I'd oh man I think
you're a real fan so it's a difference
yeah I mean [__] yeah who's not a fan of
wrestling I mean [__] losers no Bobby
Jon were right or giant hugs I am I
would you like watchu of my girl that's
an experience just take on a tangent
show but she's like you know I went to
wrestling one time when I was a kid it
came to piss rated right the
WrestleMania and I got on TV it was me
my friend into my friend's dad and we
got on TV because his dad fell asleep
was this a WC know your WTF right it was
WWF that's wrong I [__] Hulk Hogan
came through out I do that's a big deal
oh I before all the [__] I did most
I gave out of them as props that detects
Alchemist when I saw this drew bony
record cuz I'm like hold up first of all
let's be clear there's probably nobody
in the game could probably get the most
to a lot of people would consider this a
random collaboration yourself with
amigos how did this happen I wouldn't
say that like it's like when I went out
to lab with with knee goes our chief
keef like that's not red Foley sorry
people people people will be thinking
that is like so weird like I couldn't
just couldn't kick it with these people
like what like yeah I'm saying it's like
like man like like me admin and
schoolboy q's friendship is always
shocked and you guys aren't super solid
right but it's like it's like be like it
howdy was on the first bunch of NTD the
first person you what cue up q soul
I don't know I forget I don't know who
is verse on oh that will be nice ET de
yes sold my soul to a 2000 TV and that
[__] really cracked up did you uh did
you hear about friday joints yeah I love
them I just look they actually really
had me have me uh just geeked you got
more like a la I love just a real
special I just thought it was it's nice
to hear people I just like good wraps
make me happy and like um I mean I that
project would be dope if it happened it
could happen if you had to collapse it
like obviously Kendrick and kolb always
talked about doing a collaborative album
alright if you had your choice who would
you do a full full length jointly if you
had your choice crop whoever you want
Mac Miller and who um what she like a
knight like me me and you would
obviously make a really dope project but
I would want to go like do something a
little bit more on it off like a little
on like like who something maybe like
like a like am I really feel like a me
and Keith project would actually be
random and good wild because I feel like
I would like I would actually we would
have cuz okay so make you have two
records out we have that I just wanna
then we have come to check on Tasha and
I feel like like Keef spit on that [__]
on my album like he actually you got him
a rapper raps his ass on the red like
his verses pregnant so like I've I would
love to do something that but actually
up the way i'm the project I'll do
though I'll doing me a future project
well you're one of the first you add
them on the space migrations alive from
space before even anybody me if you
think I'm in the diet so it's like
futures is is the only for sure um but
yeah like I remember it's funny because
that people like her
never like iron no she could do that
[__] too but that's the only like a
course like [__] can rap like
you're saying so he's just that man is
so zoned in on what he does like last
time I saw him she's like I playing this
beat and like she just can instantly
like good like he like has his formula
was doing you can just kind of instantly
plug-in so that would be tight I just
wanna I want to do like some whole other
weird like musical [__] with him that'd
be crazy um alright so the album's out
good am go pick it up it's a [__]
amazing product definitely top ten
project of the year for sure ytb top
five um you're always working your larry
fisherman your macular you're producing
what can we expect next from Mac Miller
before I let you go all I what I really
what I would really like to do on I feel
like I really want to do some [__] like
from productions I like I want to do it
EP with somebody has a producer again
like I did the bench Vince [__] course
and I want to do something something new
with somebody and I have like I just
want to kind of just come out of the
blue with a random project so good we
need that yeah just like we need the
streets may disturb the random and for
the record not only are you one of the
most underrated wrappers on the planet
but you're one of the most [__]
underwear producers on the planet yeah
but that sometimes I need to like the
producing [__] like I I need to like
like get like start getting my [__] out
there and like really trying to be a
producer that's just hard like if you
got things like you got [__]
like like vinyls or or or [__] uh you
know like Metro boomin there's like
these these people muster they're all of
their energy you go into energy is your
energy is so I need to I need to um you
know start put some more energy into
that I make beats on tour all the time
so hard up cuz everytime I makes
really really good [__] i'll be like you
keep it do you keep it even I don't
think I gotta start like letting people
have [__] so we're not Mak appreciate
you brother now out and go pick it up
super hopefully we'll get some random
dropping sailors moon go ahead [__] the
Browns Gokai reduce these [__]
beat us in the Super Bowl yo ando night
it mad in the new pattern is essence yo
it is right you started up